hello to you Mr chaps thanks for joining
us on the program
um let's let's start with the Union
should we just finishing
um there how are you feeling about the
possibility that the military is going
to be brought in to fill the Gap should
ambulance workers go on strike
yeah I saw that story I don't think
that's actually
um correct other than to say that the
government always looks at contingency
um plans but there aren't any immediate
plans to do that and actually the NHS
has got some pretty well versed planning
in place for all manner of disruption of
course ideally uh I I I'd love to see
the those strikes averted um I don't
think anyone wants to see strikes in our
NHS it harms everybody as to no one's
advantage
okay um our nurse is worth a 19 pay rise
well we followed it's worth saying we
followed the NHS pay review body when it
comes to uh nurses
um which I think is a 1 400 pounds uh
pay rise this year it comes on top of I
think three percent last year when
inflation was lower and there were a lot
of freezes
um elsewhere uh but you know I I I'll
leave it to the to the experts on this
um and I think the main message to
everybody is and we don't want to see
strikes in our in our NHS you know we
will rely on it and um you know we want
to see it functioning normally the chap
who's now doing your former job Mark
Harper the transport secretary is saying
we can't afford
um a 10 pay rise and inflation busting
pay rise for anybody would you agree
with that
yeah I mean we've seen how this works
before
um I mean you have to go back several
decades but High inflation if you then
feed the high inflation with high
settlements you end up in a spiral where
it never ends and that's what happened
in the 1970s uh we're very determined
not to be in that situation now it won't
benefit anybody
um and you know we all know the reason
for this we all understand that Putin
invaded Ukraine pushed up Energy prices
pushed up inflation uh but we mustn't in
but mustn't chase that inflation
otherwise we won't get it out of the
system which in a year's time we will
have seen it Fallen uh to half the
current level according to the
independent office of budget
responsibility we want to see that
happen because inflation's really the
evil that we all need to defeat but for
the benefit of the whole society yeah
although you know the unions disagree
with you and they are starting to square
up to this government
um
certainly you weren't particularly
engaged with the transport unions when
you were a transport secretary um Jake
Berry the former Tory party chair
yesterday saying that was a big mistake
by you and your successor is now having
conversations with Mick Lynch and the
like
in hindsight do you think that you
should have engaged with the Union
sooner and we wouldn't have been in this
position
of course the unions were sort of
constantly saying uh we we need to speak
um although the actual discussion needs
to be between the employer and the
unions themselves and as has rather
being demonstrated in fact the last two
transport secretaries I was actually
transport secretary uh three ago uh have
both spoken to the unions it doesn't
appear to stop them from announcing a
whole new set of strikes
um so it rather proves the point that
we've all been making uh myself and the
current uh transport secretary included
which is the only way to resolve these
strikes is for the unions and the
management
um the the rail operators Network rail
to discuss these things uh and rather it
brings a lie to the idea that if only we
sat down and spoke this would all be
over as the unions have been claiming
that simply is not true because they are
still striking yeah on the contrary if
you had sat down and talked to them
perhaps you wouldn't be in this position
well why would that be the case um we're
still in that position with the last
couple why is your why is the trans
present transport secretary saying that
he will sit down and talk to them now
and you you just didn't want to
entertain them they said
because the only resolution to this is
between
um the management and uh the so you
shouldn't be chatting to them
but I mean it's not that you shouldn't
and actually I had spoken to Mick Lynch
in the past was the boss of the rmt is
simply that it doesn't seem to resolve
it one way or the other and I can prove
that point it was the last couple of uh
transport secretaries have spoken to
them uh I uh I I I I I had a situation
where I allowed the unions and the
management who were the only people who
can resolve this to speak directly
actually transpires it doesn't matter
which way you go around this at the
union seem absolutely intent on causing
the maximum disruption to hard-working
people in this country it's time for
them to stop
um grandstanding and you know get this
thing um settled fortunately actually
when it comes to rail there are lots of
modernizations that could be carried out
lots of them which could help to pay the
um their their their increase but they
don't want to modernize they want to
keep stuck in the 1970s and before
rather than modernize the railway and
that's a great shame because it's
costing all passengers a lot because of
that in transitions
talk to me about what's going on in
China you've obviously seen the images
overnight huge
let's see their biggest protest Shannon
square is what we're saying here on Sky
news this morning what does that
instability mean for us as a nation
well we're watching very carefully
indeed to see what's happening there
it's a reminder I think many of us will
have forgotten because we we haven't
been in lockdown for well over over a
year now I guess
um that is actually still going on there
and it's a reminder that the way we got
out of the situation was by having uh
Mass vaccinations uh pioneered here in
the UK with the Oxford AstraZeneca
vaccine with the UK being the first to
vaccinate and therefore the first major
economy to come out of lockdown they
didn't follow that approach in China and
said they've gone for a zero covid
um still back in the days where we'll
remember it when we were in lockdown
here and people are clearly becoming
impatient
um I I uh you know watching with with
um concern because I think it's very
important for the the question of
stability
um that for example vaccinations is is
the way forward to enable societies to
unlock
yeah but how concerned are we about that
instability I mean I know that the boss
is going to be speaking at the Guild
Hall tonight and he's going to be
talking about robust pragmatism and
that's what we need to do to stand up to
the likes of China and Russia I wonder
how that robust uh pragmatism actually
works though when we're seeing
protesters and accredited journalists um
being arrested and beaten
well there can be absolutely no excuse
whatsoever for journalists who are
simply covering uh the process going on
for being beaten by the police I know
that's a considerable concern but with
regard to The Wider issue uh you know
can you imagine have we have been locked
down for another year had we not acted
so quickly and it managed to mass
vaccinate people in this country
um I when I see those pictures it sort
of takes you back to you know the worst
days a couple of years ago of of
lockdown and people are clearly getting
pretty Fed Up about it but in terms of
our attitudes towards uh China
um it will be that robust pragmatism it
will always be saying China is a reality
but we always need to you know remind
ourselves that they do not run the same
system of democracy that we're fortunate
to live under
tell me about your energy saving
campaign that you're going to launch
today is this the same one that Liz
trust said that we weren't going to do
well all I know is about the the
campaign I am launching which is a
billion pounds
um to both help people improve money
though is it
well that's billions on top of 6.6
billion that's been spent before so this
money is for people who've not been able
to benefit from the previous schemes and
we'll help hundreds of thousands of
homes but in addition I'm also
announcing that we're going to be
helping to just to inform people better
about how they can save energy one of
the tips by the way is something I've
actually been able to use at home it's
called The Boiler flow rate and it's
actually on your boiler where you can
turn the temperature down uh which is
often set to high at 75 degrees for
example to 60 degrees this is not your
thermostat this is in the boiler itself
and it can potentially save you a lot of
money uh on your mg costs each year so
it's actually actually simple tips like
that which we'll be announcing um and
there's an 18 million pound campaign to
to back that as well so lots of
practical help physically improving
people's homes and also tips to make
sure that people are able to save
themselves money by being more efficient
in the homes
onshore wind where are you on that at
the moment
I already have plenty of a lot of
onshore wind in this country we have the
world's most offshore wind of any
country in the world
um and uh you know I think offshore has
the potential to produce really I'm sure
we already have quite a lot of onshore
wind and where do we have any more
there will be more over time but
particularly where communities are in
favor of it that is I think the key test
for onshore wind giving some benefit to
a community's locally and that's always
been a principle for us for quite some
time now
looks as though um Simon Clark former
leveling up secretary Michael Gove who
is now the leveling up secretary uh but
both backing forcing the government's
hand on onshore wind and um Simon Clark
saying they're five MPS away from
forcing the government to do what they
want I don't recognize it in those terms
at all but Simon Clark
has put in an amendment uh which I
haven't studied all the ramifications of
yet but actually essentially saying
exactly what I said to you which is that
local people ought to have
um a very very keen say in this which is
indeed government policy there are
always different ways to skin a cat as
it were
um but we'll have a close look at what's
being proposed but uh sounds like it
sounds like the government might be
backing down on this one no exactly what
we've said all along that Rishi said the
other week where onshore happens it
needs to happen we
about this I've always said
I absolutely pressed him on it and he
said he was against it he said I've
spoken the day before and he said he was
against on Sherwin so so I've always
said and indeed he has always said where
onshore wind happens it needs to happen
with local consent uh what is being
proposed uh is something which would
guarantee that local incentives to say I
haven't studied all the ramifications of
that in terms of the planning changes uh
but to present it as some sort of
massive golfers completely untrue uh you
know we need and I'll be talking about
this more later in the week I've just
talked spoken to you about measures to
reduce energy use we also need to make
sure that we reduce more energy okay
I wonder if I could ask you two very
quick questions I know you've got to
flee I just got home and she were home
secretary you were home secretary for
six days I think I'm right in saying
um I'm hearing that David Davis is
writing to the prime minister to say
that anyone from safe countries like
Albania should summarily summarily have
their applications rejected do you agree
um so what I'd say is I I you know I I
have looked at this issue in some detail
because of being briefly Home Secretary
uh where countries are not uh uh where
people's lives are more at rest and
clearly and there isn't a case for
Asylum and then clearly that should be
dealt with quickly and efficiently and
that's what I tell on that issue
um I'm so sorry but I actually have uh
one of your rival broadcasters calling
okay and I need to take their call I
think we're over time
okay we do have 12 minutes with you
don't mean we've done 12 minutes and
four seconds so let me just ask you in
another 10 seconds Matt Hancock should
he be should he be able to be back with
the Tory whip now
um look I I don't think he should have
gone to the Jungle in the first place
and you know it's often said Politics as
or show business for ugly people uh he
should be back here with us
ugly people in Parliament doing the job
for his constituents and that's that's
what I think you should have done oh
it's fun you're rather dushing actually
uh Mr chaps so it's lovely to talk to
you as always thank you very much indeed
for joining us thank you